that's so cool hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to devil
daggers now this is a game I've never
played before but it promises some
run-and-gun action with some a
horrifying video hey how's it going I
don't like is that my hand but god I
hope that's my hand because he
alternative isn't gonna go so well for
me mm-hmm
high-pitched ringing in the darkness
that's always good
also I got new glasses what do you think
are they good bad I don't know all right
should I touch the big glowing knife I
did it I did the thing about happiness
and joy oh [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god that's horrifying
but I love it whoa whoa whoa buddy all
right I don't like you I fell I did
pretty goddamn bad I need to spank the
asses ooh
okay well ah good chunks of meat
excellent and delicious and nutritious
if the only these skulls had eaten their
fill new high score so folks must have
rationalized some sort of sir some sort
of logical sense out of all this I
suppose I could go with the idea that
I'm in hell that seems to be a pretty
safe assumption in all these endeavors
crystal alright and if I'm in hell that
means that I did something to deserve
being in hell Oh God
tit wank ler hair went up almost fifty
thousand spots well that's nice that's
real nice
I'm in hell and I don't know what I need
to do to try to persuade people that I
don't deserve to be horribly maimed by
demons beyond recognition
you and your red ruby I can't get that
oh I don't want to get that holy [ __ ]
I'll come back for you later
yeah maybe I'll come for you now okay
let's go down oh how I got Teddy
sprinkled why am I here can I go home
please have you guys could
please I don't know I do a lot for you
maybe take you to a nice picnic give me
a free movie pass gift card right oh oh
why do you do that come to me come to me
[ __ ] I saw something at the darkness
that I did not like but also what am i
shooting what am i shooting out of my
fingertips
besides just like I don't know hot dogs
sausages some kind of snow some kind of
better cheddar sausages I'm not that I'm
permanently showcasing my skill for the
world to enjoy if there's one thing that
people need to learn from it's all my
mistakes when I'm battling hellish
monstrosity from beyond the grave those
guys are a permeating constant threat
and I need something better than
snausages to be able to beat them here
comes big bubble sausage oh okay so
those [ __ ] I need to take care of
hurls they're gonna get all mad at me I
need to change their diapers real quick
I don't like that's what I like what's
with the green boys I'm getting bogged
down and overwhelmed my snausages ain't
got a kind Oh I exploded into a devil
dagger okay I'm getting better at
sweeping across those guys my snausage
capabilities have increased
exponentially my hot dog fingers are
really really sassing up the place you
sucking on my rubes like all my rooms
that's right like all my rubes some oh
that is hot that is skittering demons on
the ground it's hard games hard but good
thing I'm so pro games pro up toss and
sausages sweet savory snausages I liked
the retro visual of it but I'm a bit
distracted about these guys they won't
take my offer to come on a freaking pig
come on whoa whoa whoa there's no way
that I'm gonna survive I didn't die
didn't survive that was the thing I did
not survive
I am so nice there we go yeah I'm so
nice
so I'm believably nice ah I'm twice as
nice Oh
I'm twice as nice please just let me
live man if these denizens of the deep
would just let me live for one goddamn
second I'll be able to tell them how
nice I am I'm giving you sausages show
me your big butthole
give them back give them back no no oh
this is hard this is legitimately hard
like I know there's got to be like there
was a reason that Devil dagger spawned
so I can find out how and why then I
should be able to get it again and that
will help me it's got to be the whole
concept here right oh okay I'm just in
try hard mode and I don't know why but
I'm in try hard mode and I'm gonna try
hard until I try real hard enough that I
win when I win I'm gonna kick their ass
want to kick their ass my stuff I'm so
full snausages that they're gonna be
shouting snot searches out of their
eyeballs and that's not even something
you share it's like you got to divide
your focus between what you're seeing
this game is ridiculously fun though I
will admit like it's something that's
super addictive like I know I can do
better and yet it's like super twitch
based very smart you got to do a lot of
movement it's exactly what I like out of
a game I can't say that I'm the best at
it yet because I [ __ ] hole if you
just stop shoot me into holes your
[ __ ] fan off into the abyss I'll
never be my high score but I'm gonna go
for it I just gotta get another devil
dagger whoa oh that's what
ah ah oh that's oh that's very useful
why didn't I know about that oh because
there was no tutorial and I just held
down the mouse button in a panic my just
finger SQUOZE off there cuz I wanted to
feed the hungry with the snausages that
I have maybe like the point of this game
isn't to hold down the spam but to be
economical and intelligent about where
you're placing your shots cuz they are
all grouped up so you'd think there'd be
a smart choice ah it wasn't even going
for me it was little ting confetti it's
it's the party favorite birthday Bears
ow
I give you snausages you get me your bot
holes whoa whoa whoa whoa oh come on oh
I've got so many of those things ah let
me just compare I want to see what the
best guys done not the best guy do let's
see what let's keep what castra gcamp
woo oh he's not moving wait what what is
that [ __ ] where do I get that [ __ ] what
I think it's noises are more powerful
than mine are whoa okay spoilers wait so
you only got two fingers out oh I see
right-click brings them in so I don't
need to go hunting for them I just got a
hit right click and they'll come to me
okay I'm getting it I'm learning about
this funkalicious game oh come on I was
doing great whoa
triple fingers whoa I'm powerful I'm
really powerful I beat my own score by
like a second alright you bastards last
attempt I got on this I've been playing
it up whoa hey whoa no I did
why-why-why yeah yeah yeah god damn it
you sack of [ __ ] oh just let me enjoy my
victory sorry this is gonna be the last
attempt okay got that no God [ __ ] it no
why do I keep getting distracted by the
goddamn buildings are ye oh ye oh ye
come on Oh new I score old spawning a
devil dagger thing I don't understand
that oh well it doesn't matter so that
is devil daggers super fun art crazy so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I don't know how you would survive too
terribly long in this one but some
people are better than I am so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]